Fox News alerted a suspect arrested in
the brutal killing in four College up
four college students in Idaho the
police not rolling out their other
suspects watch
is our community safe or is law
enforcement still on the search for
other suspects who might be involved in
this attack what I can tell you is we
have a individual in custody who
committed these horrible crimes and I do
believe our community is safe but we
still need to be vigilant right we still
have talked about this in the past we
always need to be aware of our
surroundings and make sure that we're
aware of what's going on
so Jimmy uh you know they're not ruling
it out the suspect uh allegedly said
when he was getting arrested that yeah
maybe that you catch someone else yep as
well what do you make of this news well
I certainly wouldn't feel any safer if I
was in that Community Based on the
answer he just gave because it did sound
a little bit evasive but there's two
things to keep in mind here one is
obviously the probable cause affidavit
that they can't speak to the specifics
of the investigation the other is we
have to be mindful of the fact that when
they are communicating with the public
they're doing so with if in fact there
is another suspect the idea that they
could be consuming this information in
mind which I think was part of the
maddening experience we had with the
Moscow Idaho messaging from time to time
during the cases a lot of people were
criticizing it as inconsistent but again
we must be mindful that sometimes
they're facing forward towards the
public with an eye on a potential
suspect consuming the information that
being said that answer was not a no you
know the only thing I took away because
I don't have the criminal justice
background of the judge or any you know
anybody on here but the point is my
horse sense told me when this suspect
said to police did you catch another guy
if you know how much time he spent
investigating these types of crimes both
as a major and a weirdo on Reddit this
does speak to maybe an evasive maneuver
by him to throw them off the scent and
potentially contaminated investigation
Katie does it concern you that there and
these play out all the time behind the
scenes but there were some
inconsistencies between the police
department and the prosecutor who's the
chief law enforcement officer of the
town he's trying to build a case uh what
he can prove in court whereas the
investigators are just grabbing evidence
as as it goes well when I first heard
what the charges were today four
accounts of first degree murder I
automatically went to well they must
have a lot of evidence that they believe
they can get him on four counts of first
degree murder there must be a lot of DNA
evidence there must be evidence of
premeditation Jimmy brings up the Reddit
post there's been talk about whether
this creep was following these students
on social media following Kaylee on
social media targeting her stalking her
and how much effort he really put into
finding a Target there was some talk
about him asking those kinds of
questions in his in his criminal justice
classes about about criminal behavior
and how they target victims we're going
to find a lot of that out it's it's
going to take a couple more weeks I I
the hearing for him in Pennsylvania is
on Tuesday and then we have he has to
decide whether he wants to be extradited
he wants to stay in Pennsylvania then
they have to issue an extradition
request for Idaho Idaho can't release
the affidavit until he gets to his
preliminary hearing so that can't be
released to the public and as you said
the prosecutor and the police today
during the press conference continued to
say wow we have a suspect in custody and
the charges have been filed the
investigation is ongoing and we're still
they said it's just the beginning and
they still want those thousands of tips
to come in if people knew something
heard something so they can continue to
build their case as Judge Jeanine was
saying up until the very moment of
prosecution in the courtroom so Joe
let's talk about that investigation
because it's going to be critical a lot
of the information was wasn't released
before still not released now because
they want to protect the Integrity of
the investigation but now we have a face
of the person that did this people who
interacted with him over though the
week's lead in the days leading up to
this uh this crime this horrific crime
do you think that's going to be critical
in this investigation oh it must but you
see what we're seeing here from the
police they are being very very close to
the vest here in terms of what they have
and what may still be out there I'm with
you Jimmy if if my kid was at the
University of Idaho and lived off campus
I wouldn't have 100 confidence that
they're completely safe right now
because it would have just been an
outright denial that there may be
another suspect so he's either playing
this this uh suspect here is playing 3D
chess by saying oh did you arrest
anybody else or maybe there was an
accomplish here we'll see but that
Reddit post is very very telling
Lawrence where he was actually putting
out a survey on victim selection that is
damning yeah this is a guy that thought
he was above the law that he can
outsmart the cops because he studied
criminals for a living yeah um Kennedy
we'll get you on the other side I will
take it yes sir hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else